you know every few days it it seems
there's another
news article blog post editorial making
the rounds
uh on facebook and and stuff with a
title like
you know why this evangelical minister
is voting for joe biden or
i'm an actual pro-life christian so i'm
voting for joe biden and camilla harris
or faith leaders back biden in sign that
evangelical support for trump is waning
the polls still say that trump is
leading as expected with protestants
though biden also as expected i'm afraid
has majority support among catholics
overall
people who qualify at least according to
pollsters as highly religious
still tend not to vote for democrats
but the trends are troubling support for
joe biden or
any other democrat candidate among
religious people ought to be steady at
around zero percent
but it's quite higher than zero and
rising
and that's a problem now i'm not here to
claim that a christian has
any obligation to vote for republicans
that's not the point of the republican
party
is not the official christian party and
christians have no obligation to it
i'm also not going to argue that donald
trump is a man of deep
faith or high moral character because i
don't believe he is
uh either of those things you know if
you happen to listen to ben shapiro show
yesterday
i agree with his take on trump and the
reasons uh
uh the reasons to vote for him that's
not going to be my focus though
whatever you decide to do on election
day what i can say
is that if you're a christian or any an
adherent to any other major religion for
that matter
you simply cannot vote for joe biden you
you can obviously in the sense that you
have the right to
and the physical ability to but you
can't do it justifiably
or in a way that is consistent with your
professed worldview
and the reason for that is very simple
let's leave aside any question of
personal character
you know i don't think that biden is
unassailably decent
and honest the way he's been branded but
never mind that
it comes down to what sorts of things
biden will do
the policies he supports the bills he
will happily sign
i would say that it's not possible to be
a decent man who enacts evil policies
but even if it is
what good is that alleged decency if a
man smiles while he punches you in the
face
your nose will be no less broken for it
and in the case of biden
the consequences are far worse than a
broken nose
like this 60 million children have
already been slaughtered by abortion
since roe v wade
the grotesque and ludicrous supreme
court decision that biden supports and
has pledged to defend with all his might
as a christian or simply as a person
with a functioning moral compass
there is no way to minimize 60 million
murdered babies
we are compelled to see it just as it is
unthinkable wickedness a historic hist
atrocity
an injustice of unfathomable proportions
joe biden intends to continue this
slaughter indeed to to fund it
after opposing tax funding for abortion
for many years biden recently
reversed himself and decided that
american citizens should be forced at
proverbial or maybe not so proverbial
gun point
to contribute financially to the
extermination of human beings
biden does not support any restrictions
on abortion biden believes that mothers
have a god-given
sacred right to execute their offspring
and he plans to do everything in his
power to protect that right
his running mate we should note is even
more radically infanticidal than he is
camilla harris has been given a 100
perfect score from
the pro-abortion group naral for a
reason
good reason and this is all that should
need to be said about good old decent
joe
it's all that a christian needs to hear
but there's more even so biden is an
enemy of religious liberty vowing among
other things
to reinstate obama's policy of forcing
nuns to allow
access to contraception bidens also said
that passing the orwellian and
inaccurately named equality act
would be one of the first priorities of
his presidency this law would make both
sexual orientation and gender identity
into protected categories
under the civil rights act meaning that
a man who identifies as a woman
would now be the victim of a civil
rights abuse should this
self-identification not be respected by
say a women's shelter that he is
demanding access to
this is not only an assault on religious
liberty as it forbids the people who run
these organizations from operating
according to their religious and moral
beliefs
but also an assault on science and basic
common sense
and decency speaking of which joe biden
very recently
endorsed the notion that an
eight-year-old boy ought to be able to
transition
into a girl now whether he really
believes this madness or not
is another question the fact remains
that he's bought into it acquiesced to
it
the most the most the most dangerous and
fantastical claims
made by the most radical elements of his
base he has acquiesced to
and pledged to govern accordingly and on
the same topic of uh
dangerous and radical elements biden is
a staunch proponent and supporter of the
racist
marxist organization black lives matter
a group that has
its spare time between fomenting race
riots and calling for the defunding of
police departments in the most
crime-plagued communities in the nation
also publicly pledged to disrupt the
nuclear family
you know this is what joe biden supports
these are the things he plans to
actually do
granted he probably won't send very many
mean tweets and his speeches will be
less
ad-libbed and probably include fewer
profanities though
there's no guarantee on that second
point but that's window dressing anyway
what should matter most to us as
christians is that
even if he's less bombastic about it
he will help to shape america into a
country that is even more hostile to
faith
even more dangerous to children even
more fundamentally opposed to us
and what we believe he doesn't deserve
our support
shouldn't receive it so do what you like
with your vote but don't use it to
undermine yourself
and the values that you supposedly hold
there